la seule opposition responsable la seule
opposition qui effectivement veut
construire la France veut réformer la
France ça a été les républicains nous
sommes la seule opposition responsable
avec deux oppositions irresponsables
nous avons d'un côté effectivement la
nupaisse sous c'est-à-dire que toute la
gauche est soumise au sens soumis qui
veut qui veut une seule chose le chaos
le chaos et puis vous avez une autre
opposition irresponsable que finalement
que la gauche que la nupes a des
diabolisé le rassemblement national qui
eux veulent quoi ils veulent
l'affrontement de tout ce contre tous et
donc ces deux oppositions là ne veulent
pas la construction de la France